kathleen madigan's comedy career has
spanned nearly three decades or more
than three decades with sold out shows
tv comedy specials and now with her do
you have any ranch tour mercedes chats
with the comedian ahead of her show at
the mirage
hi kathleen hi there i'm excited to come
i'm already packing everything's ready
what do you pack when you come to las
vegas
um a hat i make sure i have a hat and
then indoor clothes because i'm not
going out there if it's 105.
well maybe
maybe to the bar maybe
okay because i was going to say i know
you're a golfer and las vegas has some
of the greatest golf courses
yes and you if you could get out there
super duper early but when you're this
fair-skinned by like the ninth hole i'll
just pass out if it's over a hundred
yeah cause my friend my friend ron white
works there and he plays those all the
time he's like it's not that bad at
seven a.m i'm like well i don't know i
mean you have probably been all over the
world with your comedy your career is so
incredible and you just keep getting
better and better where have you been
have you been anywhere in the world
where you're like okay
this audience um
i don't think they get me
uh hong kong
really
some rich uh lady that was a friend of
princess dies just ran up and down the
vegas strip and found the comedian she
liked and she wanted to do a show for
like expats that lived in hong kong at
the time i was like okay and i mean they
flew us over there and everything but
then um when we got to the show like
half were actually just
residents of hong kong
so then they had like an interpreter
person but i kept saying what if her
timing is terrible have you ever
actually lived in las vegas
no i don't i really don't think i could
with the heat like i just i'm better at
humidity people are like whoa you're
from the midwest it gets so humid yeah
but then you're sweating and i feel like
my body's doing something in in the in
the air dry things i just feel like
you're boiling like a microwave from the
inside and then you just spontaneously
combust and you didn't know what was
going to happen because you're not
sweating i would prefer the humidity the
older i get to like i had a skin cancer
thing on my hand and the lady's like
well when did you start using sunblock
i'm like probably when i was like 30 my
parents didn't care there were too many
of us like they didn't my mom put baby
oil with iodine and then took reynolds
wrap and wrapped it around cardboard and
sat in a chair like this
and while she's smoking cigs i mean
nobody cared she's still alive she's 81
she's fine i'm just saying it's they
weren't the most health conscious
parents in the world if i'm spending my
money i'm spending it on kathleen
madigan at the mirage i
love you you're so funny and part of
this aces of comedy series that's really
a badge of honor congratulations on that
yeah thanks it's kind of cool it's very
cool to see your billboard after 30
years of working in the clubs out there
and then finally you're the the main
thing in your head's the size of seven
buildings it's it never i never don't
appreciate it i always run out and take
a picture i always get a selfie me just
going
kathleen madigan is performing at the
mirage tonight at 10 o'clock and